make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
so I'm probably a little bit late to
this party but I want to go ahead make a
video explaining Agatha Harkness right
because in the last couple days or so
we've gotten this this bit of news we're
basically Agatha Harkness is gonna be in
Wanda vision which makes sense because
in the comics she's the reason why
vision is Scarlet Witch can have kids in
the first place
believe me it gets crazy it gets wild
okay so before we get into this I want
to have an explanation about magic I'm
gonna talk about how magic works in
Marvel Comics magic really exists in a
couple different forms so what you have
is you have ambient magical energy that
comes from the universe and then you've
got extra dimensional magical energy now
what Doctor Strange does and this is the
difference between Doctor Strange and
like Agatha Harkness for example what
Doctor Strange does is he usually taps
into extra-dimensional magical energy
right a majority of doctor Strange's
power comes from something called the
vishanti now the vishanti are three
individuals named a ho cough aa store
and a komodo and these are like three
super powerful beings right they can do
almost anything they want to Doctor
Strange effectively borrows their power
I like they lend it to him and he can
use it now Doctor Strange uses basically
X to do extra dimensional magical energy
right so he taps him to the shanties
power which is you know a Trinity from
another dimension he taps into the power
of citta Rock the same guy that gave the
juggernaut his powers he uses the
crimson bands of cyttorak which if you
saw in Avengers I'm sorry in an infinity
war when like he bound doctor tried to
bind Thanos and it didn't work Agatha
Harkness more often than not taps into
ambient magical energy in the universe
meaning that Doctor Strange taps into
all kinds of different forces she's
limited not really limited but I guess
she kind of stays limited in what she
does ambient magical energy is by
definition energy that basically
emanates from eternity the cosmic entity
that being that basically represents the
sum total of the universe itself
ambient magical energy is for all
intents and purposes the exact same
thing is what Doctor Strange does the
difference is that is on a less powerful
scale right if there is such a thing
she's kind of limited motor abilities
are at the end of the day though they
can all pretty much do the same thing
and act if the Harkness can do some
pretty powerful things right she can
stop time she can teleport she can do
all kinds of crazy stuff um now when it
comes to her character she originally
debuted back in Fantastic Four issue
number 94 and it's kind of funny right
because when you go back and you read
that story she was introduced as the
governess basically the caretaker of
Franklin Richards the newborn son of a
Susan storm and Reed Richards now of
course this was back in the day before
scar
or Franklin really knew how to use his
abilities or anything like that but the
way it's alluded to in the story is that
Agatha is aware of Franklin Richards and
what he can do by the fact that he's
like a reality wore fur that he's
exceedingly powerful Agatha Harkness
seemed to be aware of this but it's kind
of funny the way that it's written
because Stan Lee and Jack Kirby back
then comics were just sort of they're
right it's like it's a thing that's
happening and like that's basically yeah
I get the Harkness is contacted by the
Fantastic Four to be a a caretaker for
Franklin due to the dangerous life of
the Fantastic Four but it's never
explained one how they found out about
her and two why they're taking him there
outside of her being being you know his
caretaker because one of the things are
they saying the story is well I really
hope she's safe well you would hope that
if you're gonna take your child to be
taken care of by someone that you would
have at least vetted them or known who
they are but the reality is that she was
introduced just for the purpose of kind
of you know applying that real life
element to Marvel Comics by Stan Lee
insofar as the Fantastic Four kind of
mirrored the real world back then back
in the 1960s but also because of the
fact that if Franklin was gonna be taken
care of by somebody it would have to be
somebody within it with some real
measure of power and the result was that
for the most part you didn't really see
a whole lot of those characters there
back then and so what ended up happening
is that during the time when the
Fantastic Four took Franklin Richards to
Agatha Harkness a group called the
frightful four was reforming now the
frightful four was basically the
antithesis to the Fantastic Four right I
mean hence the reason why their names
are so similar but the funny thing about
this is that when the Fantastic Four
basically settling down the frightful
four make their move to attack the
Fantastic Four and when this happens a
fantastic four more or less locked away
they're essentially kind of kind of
imprisoned by the the frightful four
and then Agatha Harkness deals with him
with a quickness it's insane and there's
a hilarious moment where she's like you
wouldn't harm a little old lady would
you and they're like we don't care she's
a glide you and she's like magic this is
like she wins and that's basically it
like she just wins because of magic I'm
the funny thing about this is that
Agatha Harkness never really had a like
a huge overarching hand in the Fantastic
Four stories instead she was more of a
support character whenever the Fantastic
Four went off on various adventures
she'd be the one taking care of Franklin
and that's reason why you always kind of
got these indications over the years in
a time the Agatha Harkness took care for
the richer's that he was going to become
somebody's super powerful because she
always kind of had these indications
that was gonna be the case now it's not
to say that Stan Lee and Jack Kirby and
Marvel never tried to flesh her
character out and if
during Fantastic Four issue number 186
as well as Silver Surfer volume 1 issue
135 and the 2008 story of marvel
Atlantis with issue number 1 I think it
was what you got was this kind of
backstory of a cat the Hartness and what
we ended up finding out here is that
Agatha Harkness is about 10,000 and 500
years old right she's exceedingly old
she's been around for a very very long
time but we don't really know anything
about her origin besides that all we
really know that came after that is
sometime between the time that she was
born and the fall of Atlantis which
happened about five hundred years later
and then the ten thousand years
following that she ended up in a colony
in Colorado referred to as New Salem now
New Salem was established as a safe
haven for wizards witches warlocks
different things like that following the
the witch hunts the Salem witch trials
but for New Salem itself it could only
be accessed by individuals who knew how
to use magic right so it was very Harry
Potter esque in terms of how it
functioned the idea behind this though
was that for some reason or another
which is never fully explained in Marvel
Comics due to the fact that Agatha
Harkness his backstory is still very
much a mystery she ended up leaving and
basically traveling throughout the
mortal world and so some you know some
time between when that happened and when
the Fantastic Four met her she just took
up residence at a place called whisper
hill and just resided there now when you
got to Fantastic Four you see number 186
this introduced a group that was
basically referred to as the Salem seven
of what you ended up finding out is that
Agatha Harkness had had a son named
Nicholas scratch and Nicholas scratch
had successfully managed to take over
New Salem and then basically tricked all
these people into believing that Agatha
Harkness had effectively committed
treason by not only leaving New Salem
but then associating with do it with a
group called the Fantastic Four who were
non magic wielders so as a result of
that I got the Harton as the Fantastic
Four Franklin Richards were all were all
basically taken eventually the Fantastic
Four were able to free themselves and
rescue Agatha Harkness and then they
ended up travelling back now for
Nicholas scratch himself he ended up
trying to come back a few times and
ultimately he was defeated each time
usually by Agatha Harkness sometimes
with the help of the Fantastic Four and
that was really about it but because of
the fact that magic and Marvel Comics
was starting to be explored more than it
had been before
specifically because Scarlet Witch was
becoming more of a prominent character
within the pages of The Avengers
eventually in 1985 with a second
iteration of a vision of Scarlet Witch
you ended up getting Stevie Englehart
rolling the character over into that
story
and the reason for that is because for
for Scarlet Witch she was essentially
being tutored by Agatha Harkness but
then the question began to arise is it
possible for Scarlet Witch and vision to
start having kids and so in issue number
three
Agatha Hartness as the mentor of the
teacher of scarlet which was basically
recaptured by the Salem seven and then
successfully burned at the stake and so
during that time period when she
essentially died her magical energy in
her essence in some ways basically was
gathered together by one of the members
of the Salem seven named vertigo who
wasn't able to control it and so what
the Scarlet Witch it's such a engaging
the team in battle vertical lost control
of those magical energies Scarlet Witch
took some of them and then was basically
met with a kind of spiritual presence of
Agatha Harkness who guided Scarlet Witch
to the process of impregnating herself
using those magical energies and then
ultimately having kids now for Agatha
she stayed gone for a little bit of time
here but the reason why this matters is
because during the time and vision and
Scarlet Witch was written by Steve
Englehart Jim shooter was editor in
chief the vision the Scarlet Witch story
was essentially designed to be
self-contained didn't really tie into
anything
it was a story focusing explicitly on
these two characters and essentially
nothing else's so in a lot of ways for
readers of the time it felt like an
isolated story that was removed from
continuity it didn't take place when
everything else took place the problem
with this is that in 1989 by that point
in time Tom DeFalco had become
editor-in-chief and looking at vision
and Scarlet Witch and seeing the idea at
the Scarlet Witch had basically knocked
herself up using a magical energy that
belonged to a witch who is essentially
dead just seemed nonsensical and so in
West Coast Avengers 51 and 52 by John
Byrne I got the Hartness had somehow
managed to return and then you
alternately ended up learning that the
children that Scarlet Witch was walking
around with we're basically aspects of
the demon Mephisto and so Mephisto
essentially absorbed those children back
into himself and due to the trauma and
the heartbreak I get the Hartness to
basically wipe the mind of the Scarlet
Witch so she didn't know that she had
any kids at all she never realized that
they had existed in any form or fashion
and so following that I get the Hartness
largely became a huge background
character you almost never saw her the
only time she'd ever really pop up but
the only time he'd ever really see her
is in stories like Avengers issue number
503 when she's basically helping Scott
at which control her chaos magic cast
magic is one of those debatable terms in
Marvel Comics even within like the comic
book itself Doctor Strange kind of made
the case that there is no such thing as
chaos magic the reality was it seemed to
have been proven true at the time that
it was it was more or less accepted by
Marvel and so far the chaos magic was
essentially Scarlet Witch
channeling the power of cthe on this
insanely powerful demon entity that at
one point managed to successfully
dominate the world but aside from those
appearances here and there you didn't
really see a whole lot of Agatha Hardin
she was just sort of there and just kind
of around really her be involved in
helping to quote-unquote Train Scarlet
Witch in the use of her powers there's
really more designed for the purpose of
beefing up the Scarlet Witch try making
her more interesting but especially when
it comes to Avengers issue number 503
was tying into Avengers disassembled and
that basically went into the idea that
somehow Scarlet Witch had basically
relearned that she had children at one
point or belief she did ended up
tracking down Agatha Harkness due to the
fact that Agatha had wiped her mind
during a West Coast Avengers 51 and 52
and then as a result ended up killing
Agatha Harkness and that's really the
last time you see her you don't really
see her again until about 13 years later
and Scarlet Witch wrought by James
Robinson which came out in 2017
now while James Robinson Scarlet Witch
series really like changed a lot of the
scarlet witch's origin right like giving
her biological mother an actual name in
the form of Natalya Maximoff so on and
so forth changing the origin of her
character we're trying to tie it into
what Marvel had done with regards to
like Magneto and all those various
things one of the big things to come out
of it was the introduction of something
called the goddess of Witchcraft and the
guise of witchcraft was his concept was
introduced it basically established that
when it came to characters like Agatha
Harkness where previously it was
believed that she tapped into the powers
or basically the the power of eternity
itself which is to say the ambient
magical energy the reality of this is
that the goddess of witchcraft is worth
where I get the Hartness drew her power
from and is a means by which any witch
or wizard or warlock this is essentially
not Doctor Strange using the powers
elected Ishod to your sidorak or
anything draws their power from and so
it really kind of gave a source for
house how I get the hardnesses abilities
function for all intents and purposes it
still amounts to the same thing it's
just a different energy source so it's
really not a great big huge difference
there but the overall idea behind this
is that Natalia Maximoff ended up
sacrificing her her essence along with
the Scarlet Witch sacrificing her soul
and then working alongside I got the
Hartness to essentially save and free
the goddess of witchcraft and when that
was done Agatha Harkness was resurrected
as well the issue with that is that was
a couple years ago but Agatha Harkness
has never really played a role in Marvel
Comics since she's there but nothing's
really happening with her character and
that's really kind of the way that it's
been right I mean she's always just kind
of been a background character I would
surmise The Closer that we get to 2021
and the closer that we get to the launch
of the Wanda visions show
a high likelihood of marble either
introducing her more or creating like a
whole new Scarlet Witch envision series
and then Agra the Hartness play more of
a role in that series that's closer in
line to how she's gonna be depicted in
the TV show and that kind of makes sense
right because I get the Hartness is
obscure enough and she's she's really
she's been a background character enough
times and hasn't really done enough that
Marvel can do pretty much anything they
want with her and it'll fly right
because for most people out there it'll
be the first time they've ever heard of
her character when they sit down and
they watch the show right I would
surmise then until Agatha Harkness was
mentioned as being part of Wanda vision
nobody'd ever heard of her I like most
people as you were a hardcore comic
reader had never heard of Agatha
Harkness and that kind of makes sense
but I mean she's just not super
important here but hopefully this video
helped to educate you guys and give you
guys an idea of what this carrot was
about and what she's capable of again
she was a caretaker for for Franklin
Richards of the Fantastic Four for a
number of years she trained Scarlet
Witch and then eventually scrawled at
which killed her that's basically the
characters history summed up in like
five seconds so without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
it make sure you guys to the sub button
to become part of the rob Court if you
guys want to see my uncensored videos my
early access videos and my vs. videos
make sure you head over to patreon calm
calm it's explained and if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
first we've got some new patrons in our
top tears over on patreon comm slash
comments explained I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Jason s
Austin H Phillip and Austin B as well as
Steven Z Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as
well as Genesis 916 as always we just
usually keep the last name - an initial
it helps you guys to maintain your
anonymity some of you guys are expressed
concerned about having like your first
and last name thrown out there for the
world to see I do not blame you for you
guys who have joined up as part of our
patreon tiers that are eligible for Rob
for honor guard rings those whose rings
have been sent out you should already
have them if you're a new person who
just joined up and you've been part of
this here for a month your ring will be
mailed out to you so I want to say thank
you guys for beatin patrons
[Music]